[Music]
five [__] time to tell Harvey
Weinstein it's over we're going deep
tonight into the murky waters I'm happy
you came by
fine oh it's gonna be a good night
[__] I can feel my drum perking
already
it's more those type of nice
[__] if you're under 18 hang up
now because we're going deep deep deep
deep tonight you understand me I know
I've said that many times before but
this party don't end tonight tell
ambulance shows up I got an ambulance on
call you don't say no yes I do I got
[__] bored some people got a little
boy I got I got an ambulance driver go
get leave in no time
put away the [__] whip the pony's
dead [__] you guys want it you
got it
we're doing everything tonight we got a
nurse we got everything we got [__]
interns now starting this week it's
gonna be all over fine
[Music]
that's how we're starting this mother
[__] off tonight Sunday whatever the
[__] it is October 29 put away your
[__] masks
it's [__] the real Halloween tonight
tomorrow nice Devils night for you
[__] know anything about that
[__] but obviously you don't Devil's
Night when you sacrifice a [__]
we're doing that tonight here we got an
ambulance on call we got all types of
edibles look at this [__] stack a
[__] [__] we got here we got
everything tonight if you were thinking
of calling in to where y'all berth does
call into sick [__] you you ain't going
to work till Wednesday after I get a
hold do you understand me your little
miserable [__] and if you're
under 18 you better hang up now cuz
we're gonna take this [__]
party to write to a rehab we're taking
this bus to a rehab it's over so by
October it's over and we took it to the
next level
you want to solve a little [__] rehab
here on the church there's no sober
ducted that's a little half a [__] clouds
I got some [__] coming for your ass in a
second my trusted little servant over
here my Goomba
[Music]
why so many because this [__] Sunday
we practice what we preach here you want
some [__] [__] us go to another
[__] [__] bud gasps ah I need to
count my edibles I'll get the [__] out
of here it's Sunday night we go into
Monday's under water when I wake up on a
Monday I don't know where the [__] I am
and that's how I like it
you understand me who the [__] needs to
know where you are that's for [__]
these people put money away every week
and thinking 30 years they're gonna be
rich suck my dick all right you live for
today [__] leave what's going
on with those stars this year
just imagining you way huh
I do that every morning if you wake up
and you know who you are you ain't
living you ain't [__] living you
understand me look at this [__] we're
going down deep into the murky waters
I'm taking my time cuz the guest is
gonna be late
listen I don't care if you got a robbed
grandma grandpa you ever smoked you ever
snort one of those chemo pills let me
taste them you got a cheese granny you
[__] you get that chemo pill you snore
don't [__] line it it's all over
you'll be having fireworks and [__] you
think you're in Vegas people getting
shot it's all over because you want to
pet great into a powder we're not
[__] around till I understand what we
got Khushi's tushies and lucious I want
to see nothing but [__] and elbows
and don't forget Thursday Friday
Saturday Omaha Nebraska Saturday early
show is already sold out what does that
tell you stop [__] around and let's
go the party begins Thursday night look
at this gah gah gah gah gah gah
Bobbo we don't [__] around you ain't got
time to think men who think of [__] up
when you think as a man that's when you
get in trouble boom there's no time to
think you want to think go hang out with
your [__] friends at Starbucks you can
think about the future
someday I'm gonna go to Europe who gives
a [__] you ain't gonna do dick you ain't
gonna do dick the closes you come to
Europe is even one of these [__]
edibles alright that's the closest you
ever come to Europe or or Bangladesh I
can't wait to go to Fiji yet into what
suck more dick than you're suckin here
you waitin at the Fiji those
[__] ain't got vitamins in
their food if you think might come
tastes bad wait till you taste some
Island native [__] juju juices [__]
here we go look at this beautiful no
hesitation
just like that you wanna [__] around go
[__] around somewhere else when you're
here with the church we go deep in the
Voodoo Lounge will you wake I already
had two [__] things I'm about to have
the last let's go come on
oh wait don't be olfi don't be
[__] Wayne got time to be [__]
around shoutouts to Lukey spooky Cleo my
main man
Timmy Juliet in Secaucus what a [__]
[__] out there Federal Express in fact
we're running like 2,000 pounds of yo-yo
out of Bogota the Secaucus fell Express
I hope the DEA in on it
the cops are covered Oh tell them I did
nothing and if they call your house
don't answer the phone
you know saying look at this we don't
give a [__] here Monday tomorrow never
comes [__] tomorrow never [__]
Cubs you living for today bears man look
at this BAM what's this this is crazy
heads right when your ballad is for the
spear fingers I don't give a [__] I'm
looking for a Jew attorney but vastly on
his fingers you don't saying that's what
I'm looking for it's time for a bong
Italy welcome to my show yeah I'm saying
welcome to my [__] world here listen
I said a welcome to my show
she went me baby let's give me a little
[__] Chocolate Chunk this [__] Oh
Joran down on me when I'm on fire
very nice
Chocolate Chunk people ready this this
is a real [__] indica no [__]
around old people give my brother Lee
and I slip on him
look at that see I think a toenail no
toenails that's other weed I'm bringing
Wednesday
[Music]
but you will [__]
there you go [__] stage fright I
want you to know waves flopping around
here - let me try to tell you people for
six years and for six years you tuned in
and you're like Joey what the [__] you
people are savages the only way to be
you want to [__] around go somewhere
else
[__] around
[Music]
we gotta fill this up fully I gave a
little half of backbone
I gotta give the real [__]
well if we got here we have to chocolate
oh [__] we got the [__]
perennial there's a tremendous knocking
out my Romanian 1983 many of those into
this house in a closet figuring out what
to do with my life Wow
[Music]
boom you're going from my head you're
going down oh [__] he's going down what
are you [__] nuts - what what's the
score [__] still seven two four
that's a good [__] game ladies and
gentlemen bleep let's go here we go into
the murky waters do the breathing this
is
[Music]
all the way spit out that baddie out of
your lungs we got things to do and
people to see
don't forget 1-800 bum taken to going
quick for next summer's extravaganza you
too can learn how to do a bong it like a
savage
[Music]
that's the one that's the one that's the
one that's the one that's the one all
the way all the way one-shot deal there
you go hold it it and you don't let you
go there you go there you go you broke
up you took it to the next level there
you go
you follow me and in the bong hit do you
have drool on your beat you follow me if
I had a beard and have drool over at all
times to prove to you people that we
don't [__] around here you know I'm
saying you want to keep doing you little
[__] [__] paper pens trying to
impress you little [__] [__] friends
dad be my guest but there ain't nothing
like smoking the route get I'm saying
you can make a rubber boat robot to suck
your dick but you ain't gonna suck the
route like a real one it's too late too
late too late for love oh [__]
you [__] wanted trouble you got
it and now you can't leave how you like
me now here we go forget that [__] the
face of my brother thank you very much
how was the bond I tell you we got
another one for you with your neighbor
[__] it yeah you gotta clean all the
pipes I'd cousin uncle Joey gives you a
bonnet I give you a bum
you understand me do not come to the
Voodoo Lounge and you're gonna [__]
alone but then time for another
perennial pumpkin this is the [__] that
killed Abe Lincoln
one minute you're smoking it the next
minute you're writing the Emancipation
Proclamation you follow me
we want to [__] around with huh you want
to deal with somebody you want to deal
with uncle Joey man remember
will you [__] [__] when your names
on the list those people on a list you
want those people on your list and you
can't have those people around you gotta
hang out with people like uncle Joey
listen I got nothing but heart and
[__] balls I'm a little [__] up I'm
gonna [__] I hear voices I have weird
scenarios I got PTSD but the hearts all
there [__] and that's what you're
looking for in an uncle I don't gotta
sell this [__] you know that let's do
another pump right or wrong it's not the
Lord's Day till you do a few [__]
bong neurones here we go
[Music]
oh [__] Mountain Bow Bells found their
new oh [__] to lay full of it's too late
[Applause]
what do you want - we want them you want
to keep hanging out skipping rope you
listen I'm gonna put the app off pretty
soon uncle Joey's [__] bong hit camp
stay away from micro doses and all those
people I'm gonna teach how to swim
without a snorkel and I'm saying look at
least pull over they recover so you
don't practice all weekend he has time
to go to pub conventions and [__] like
that I leave him a bar I give them weed
here we go it's too late
[Music]
to lay full uh yeah yeah
great [__] out tremendous out
[Music]
and you think you got some problems the
next [__] [__] that face times me
while I'm doing a periscope tell me
you're that theater scope me or dare
[__] call this number when we're
[__] periscoping you cannot be that
[__] stupid knock it off
[__] calling me while I'm trying to
[__] periscope are you [__]
[__] what's wrong with people can
you tell me that and you [__] believe
these [__] retards anyway it's a
beautiful night October [__] 29th
Wednesday it's a new month you [__]
55 or what days away from the holidays
get your [__] together stop [__]
around stop worrying about dumb [__]
things focus life is passing you by for
40 years I walked around in a [__]
coma or duh-duh-duh-duh-duh then I came
to an end one day now I'm telling you
you don't have to live in that [__]
coma snap out of it you smoke with your
weed you do your [__] jumping jacks
and you keep your head pictures and
[__] the [__] is wrong with people
here we go
batter now nano now look at least
sitting there with a face going and
where's my bump
I don't don't worry about the start you
still got a thousand [__] things
let's see I ate everything an hour ago
these two things that's it that's it
what's so [__] finish what's out fast
take this [__] like three hours to
eat two little stars he's sitting there
like a kid like I don't want to eat no
more eat the [__] thing that's it
that simple look at them into Church of
tape oh [__]
the only bottles in the back they're
young oh [__] you don't know how to
change from bad to good here we go
I better hop on up who's ready for a
bong hit and Sunday night open up your
[__] baby uncle Joey's coming to town
Omaha Nebraska
Thursday Friday Saturday and Saturday
Early's already sold out get your [__]
together and the week after that me and
Dean Dell Rizzi
Friday Saturday 4th shows Gotham comedy
club in the heart of [__] New York
City now what the [__] else do you need
huh huh you know I love your mother
[__] I got a test you see I got you
there
back in the city he's a man of ocean
let's go for some [__] perennial it's
time to see the devil listen you come to
the Voodoo Lounge this is the closest
you'll ever come to seeing the devil you
got to go to Africa the pump into that
[__] and that's on a good night
he might be in Antigua [__] like that
what's up dawg we sit there going holy
[__] I hope zip recruiter finds me a new
job I can't take this no more he goes to
[__] therapy everything just sits
there I don't know what I'm gonna do the
bond gets just don't stop we don't [__]
around please yo
all right the church where happening now
in a [__] you know it's a state of
mind [__]
[Music]
I love what we get we have clean and
sober guests as a you don't mean I'm
clean and sober too
[Music]
beautiful night man
when our sweet as family could sit here
listen to a side of an owl
smoke a few bonnets get a few laughs
boob write a little bit this is what
it's all about this is what the church
what's happening now it's all about it's
not about listen we all put our pants on
one leg at a time I'm saying it's gonna
be a good [__] week the best thing
about you is you're young you got the
world by the balls you don't give a [__]
understand me all these [__]
selling their soul showing their titty
for a movie role suck my dick
we show up strong you follow me that's
all I got for you [__] god
bless you [__] have a great
week uncle Joey loves you
I'll see you this weekend at Omaha on
the following weekend in New York City
at the bad big [__] Apple so you do
what you need to do you know I love you
stay black remember I'm with you you're
with me and they wanna be with us you
understand me there's my brother Theo
one boy oh [__] oh [__] strap on a pair
[__] we're going deep tonight
I'll see you guys in 10 minutes
youtube.com slash see it's last Joey
Diaz that's the place to be and remember
at the end of the week that didn't get
my math or our big guy but get booked at
the Runkle alcoholic that's why have a
great week stay black see you in 10
minutes and remember if they try to
sexually assault you tell them to suck
your dick suck my dick BAM